post millennial has uh
this uh article during Monday's episode
of ABC's the view the co-host
conversation about Martin Luther King Jr
Day Led to sparring over how learning
about slavery and other human rights
abuses in American history should make
white students feel while Anna Naro
argued that nobody should feel bad while
being taught about the past simply
because of the color of their skin Sarah
Haynes was adamant in her belief that
white children must feel responsibility
for the actions of their forefathers uh
here's the kid quick one I think there's
there's more to it than that look I
think what it is is that um black
history and other things Banning books
has been weaponized for political
purposes to drive people to the polls
based on outrage because my poor little
white kid is feeling bad because he's
learning about slavery that's ridiculous
learning about history should not make
anybody feel bad we learn about history
should make you feel bad but it's
important that it makes you feel I don't
think it should make you feel bad I mean
I don't think a white child uh that's
had nothing to do with slavery should
feel bad about slavery I think we need
to learn history so that we don't repeat
the same mistakes about history the
thing that people are uh focusing on in
that clip is the the conversation about
how white kids should feel but even
before you get there you know just even
even the phrase poor little white kid oh
you're poor little white kid this is
once again uh this total contempt and
Scorn being heaped on white people uh
without without you know
without without hiding it without
covering it without without feeling the
need um to hide to hide it at all
and all you have to do is imagine what
it would sound like for someone to say
oh you're your poor little black kid
your poor little black kid
boohoo it's like you you just you can't
imagine
anyone on television using that phrase
like in any context you just can't
imagine it it would never
happen um and yet there
is there's there's no compunction
there's no don't hesitate at all to use
this kind of language I'm talking about
white people and and and you
know it it can it's not sustainable I
guess is the point um and people like me
have been warning this for a long time
and you can you can reject the warnings
but it it is just not
sustainable you
cannot take one and I think history has
taught us this history has taught us
this again and again and
again um it's maybe one of the primary
lessons that history teaches
us you you cannot take a group of
people and make them the villains make
them the bad
guys and just Heap nothing but scorn and
contempt on them all the time
and expect it to just continue that
way um without any blowback without any
pushback and everything's going to be
fine you can't you can't expect
that
um and it's it's really as simple as
that now obviously the stuff about
slavery is completely ridiculous now if
you mean that kids should feel bad in
the same way
that you know you feel sad when you read
about any bad thing that happened in his
history like if you read about the
Titanic sinking uh does that make you
feel bad I mean doesn't make you feel
good right it's it's a sad thing so you
you have feelings of sadness when you
hear about a tragedy that occurred in
history but um feel bad usually means
feeling responsible feeling guilty it's
like when you've done something say I
feel bad about that which is why nobody
would ever say I feel bad about the
Titanic sinking I feel really bad about
that geez sorry about that I feel bad
because it makes it sound like you're
holding yourself responsible for the
sinking of the Titanic which of course
makes no sense it it equally makes no
sense to say that about slavery you know
I feel bad about it me I feel bad I
didn't have nothing to do with
it so no in that sense of course white
kids shouldn't feel bad about slavery in
that in the sense of feeling guilty and
responsible which is the sense that it
was meant there but of course the whole
premise of the conversation is totally
false um and we keep it you know it's
what one false premise after another
from the left this is this is maybe the
most among the most absurd of all of
them is
this that there are people out there who
are
objecting to the to to to slavery being
mentioned in a historical context at all
which is not happening nobody objects to
white kids or kids of any race learning
about slavery in History Class I've not
heard one single
person ever say that which is really
saying something because you could take
any you take any idea any like nutty
crazy idea these days especially you
could probably find at least somebody
who believes
it but at this case I I have not heard
this anywhere I have not heard one
single person ever say that we shouldn't
be teaching about slavery in school I've
not heard I've never heard that as we
head towards a presidential election in
November there's one thing you can be
sure of 2024 will be a tumultuous year
how will your hard-earned savings Fair
well you already see the impacts of
inflation at the pump and the grocery
store the dollar continues to lose
buying power fast and wages can increase
how are you protecting your savings
consider diversifying with gold from the
Birch gold group for decades gold has
been the choice of investors and central
banks to hedge against inflation if you
have an IRA 401K from a previous
employer that's just Gathering dust call
Birch gold and they will help you
convert it into an IRA in Gold you won't
pay a penny out of pocket they'll simply
convert that 401k into physical gold
which unlike digital currency can't be
tampered with just text Walls to 98 9898
and Birch gold will send you a free info
kit on gold with an a plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and the exclusive gold
company with the daily wire for S years
running you can trust Birch gold text
Walls to 98 9898 to claim your free info
kit that's Walsh to 98
9898 and secure your savings now uh the
point about slavery aside from the one
that I've made many times which is that
a real study of slavery should be far
more expansive to include uh you know
the fact that slavery was a global
Institution for Millennia so if anything
you know my point about it is that no we
shouldn't be saying less about slavery
we should be saying more about it
actually I mean it is one of the one of
the
um one of the significant facts of of of
of the history of human civilization is
that this institution existed for
thousands of years and uh and it's it's
very interesting to think about why that
was the case how did this come about in
the first
place um how is it that for thousands of
years Humanity took this for
granted and for thousands of years
really really almost nobody even thought
to object like honestly for thousands of
years it really didn't even occur to
anyone that there might be a problem
here um and that includes many uh many
of the Great Geniuses of History it
didn't appear to have a fundamental
issue with the institution of slavery
all across the world that is uh that's
an interesting fact you know it's it's
also a tragedy it's terrible but it's
like it's interesting like that's
something you could try to figure out
how how is it how could you have this
kind of global blind
spot that that so many people shared for
thousands of years um so yeah that
should that should be a subject of of
historical investigation but it's not
because when we talk about sa we only
talk about it in the most limited way
possible um because we are not allowed
to admit that every other race of people
are also guilty for this institution
that existed for thousands of years but
aside from all that um at a more
fundamental level the point about
slavery is that it is a historical
subject it is a matter of history and it
should be studied and viewed that
way and so as far as I'm concerned as
long as we're doing that it's a it's a
historical subject it's not something at
least in this country that exists today
or that people today are responsible for
at least in this country have to keep
qualifying that way uh because it does
exist in other parts of the world
especially in non-white parts of the
world
um uh and it and it's a it's a it was a
much more expansive phenomena
uh than what we're told so like those
are my two points about SL I that's the
point that most people
make uh if they have any objection at
all about the way that it's to the way
that it's taught thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast